hello everyone if you've seen my video
yesterday it's also a game between
Sergey Karjakin with the white pieces
and Andre I see pink with the black
pieces as a panko plate probably the
most beautiful game of the entire world
to rap a championship he defeated
Carioca in a beautiful miniature I
called it the Russian beauty since it
resembles Frank Marshalls American
Beauty and this is a game from around
nine of the world blitz championship it
was played some half an hour ago while
I'm making this video and now again two
of them face and again Kara Kane has the
white pieces so probably you know
Kerrigan definitely wants to get his
revenge and he was probably pretty
furious yesterday when he lost to his
countrymen in in such a beautiful game
you know if you lose a game like that
against a fifteen-year-old feed a master
and you are Sergei kurakin you were last
year's blitz a world champion and also
the Challenger for the title against
Magnus Carlsen it's it's not a pleasant
thing to experience so in this game Cara
can opens up with v3 the names of each
Larsen attack we have E 5 Bishop to b2
Knight to c6 III Knight to f6 and Bishop
to b5 and this is a very I mean it's a
very decent opening for white I actually
used this idea twice against the
national master also here from the city
where I live and I managed to win one
game and draw one game so the idea is
you want to capture this night and after
black recaptures would be captures on c6
the rook can come to the open B file but
it doesn't really matter it's it's the
same I open B file as you already have
b3 played and there is no real danger
from this rook here but here as he panco
plays Bishop to d6 I don't think I've
ever seen this move we have Knight 2 8 3
by Carrick in efore now Knights the c-4
going after the bishop on d6 Bishop to
e7 and beat the bishop characters on c6
but now D captures on c6 is played and
knife to e2
if I look at this position this is
probably the position I've never seen
that arises from the names of each
Larsen attack it seems better for black
than the other positions that I've
already seen so as a bank of castles
Carrick in castles and we have c5 here I
don't really understand the idea behind
c5 probably to control d4 but I don't
know probably to control d4 Knight to g3
by kurakin we have worked to e8 and f3
now and here is a Benko place he
captures on f3 and this wasn't problem
this wasn't the best move a better idea
was to play b5 as this night doesn't
really have a lot of squares to go to he
can go to a3
but what's it really doing on a3 after
rook to b8 it's gonna be stuck on a 3 so
after something like Knight to e5 and
Bishop to d6 no there's a double attack
on the night you don't really have a
square for this night you have to play
something like you can go knight c6 but
this doesn't really do anything extra
Queen to d7 probably you have to push f4
and now you black keeps his pawn on e4
and you simply continue playing this
game with for example a 5 or maybe even
a 6 but ok after f3 as a banker played
it captures on f3 we have Queen captures
on f3 and now there is this annoying
battery of Queen and rook that eyes that
f7 pawn so as panco brings the rook back
rook back to f8 and maybe it's also
treason maybe as a banquets I've been
nervous as he knows Carquinez is coming
for revenge
efore by kurakin and the Bishop to g4
Queen to f2 bishop goes back to e6 and
Huracan plays d3 we have Knight to g4
now attacking the Queen on f2 I don't
really think there is a plan here Queen
2 F 3 and B 5 now Knight goes to a5 and
Bishop to f6 that was the plan
play Knight g4 kicked the Queen kick the
knight to the edge of the board on a5
and exchange the dark square bishop so
the night from g4
can recapture on f6 Bishop captures
Knight captures and a for now we have a
six and Quinta III now by Kirk in
attacking the c5 pawn Knight to d7
defending it
we have Knight to c6 would attempt on
the Queen and now Queen comes to h4 we
have Knight to f5 by kurakin attacking
the Queen Bishop captures rook captures
and rook e8 e8 by se panco and this is
definitely the critical moment of the
game a hurricane's position is much
better and here he should probably
continue the game with something like a
capture some b5 a capture some b5 and
maybe a rope to a7 going for the c7 pawn
but in this position kurakin made a
blunder and it's a pretty big blunder
but neither can nor
young-se Pengo here actually registered
that it was a blunder here Cara can
played rook to d5 he played this with an
attack on the d7 night kind of seems
like it comes over the tempo and here I
see panko played a queen to g4 to defend
the night but instead of this move both
of them obviously missed this you have
this Queen to f6 move and Queen to f6
move pretty much wins the game here for
four for AC panco as it comes up with a
double attack on the night here and also
the rook is attacked on a1 so if you
want to protect the rope you have to
move the rook simply Queen captures
night then you protect your own night on
d7 and if rook captures Knight Queen
captures rook this is what check you can
bring the Queen back and I mean it's
it's a winning position whether he would
win it or not it's I mean that's a
different question
but yeah the Queen to f6 both Cara
cannon I see panko missed this move
so after up to d5 I see panko played the
Queen to g4 to defend his knight on b7
Queen to g3 now Cara can offers the
exchange of Queens and you can't really
accept this if you accept the Queen
trade Queen captures H captures I mean
trading Queens is probably the best
thing for AC panko but white
simply so much better the rook and
Knight will and the other rook is coming
into the game all of these pawns will
fall
so after up the Queen to g3 Queen to e6
by spangle he gives up the c7 pawn at
least against some counter play so
Kerrigan grabs it we have Knight to f6
now Cara King revs another pawn as well
King to h8 we have Knights to d4 would
attempt on the Queen Queen to g4 and now
Knight to f3 rook the c8 attacking
Kerrigan's queen and Cara Kim plays
Queen to b6 defending his rook on c5 and
here I mean it's a winning position for
white there's simply too much material
advantage a car cane is up two pawns and
those are two beautiful pawns so it's
hard to find a move here for black
probably you want to play either rook F
to d8 or something you have to exchange
one pair of rooks maybe put before or
something but here in this position I
see panco actually played rukka captures
on c5 probably with the idea
Kerrigan will recapture and then he will
just continue playing this game but in
this in this position car can actually
played a much better move I'm sure all
you can see that move I will give it a
couple of seconds just if you want to
really study the position in this
position Cara can simply played Queen
captures on f8 and this is what check
and in this position
Andres pinko resigned the game as the
King has nowhere to go you have to block
this with the 998 and and only now will
the Queen recapture the other rook on c5
Black is done a rook there is no point
in playing this game so this is this is
Carrigan's revenge I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and I would like to thank
Locutus the Borg and the Gregory harvest
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot that really appreciated all
the critters the Borg is actually the
first person that has ever contributed
to my channel and it is in fact because
of the feeders the Borg that I have
allowed contributions on my channel he
requested in the comments so I'm very
I'm very happy to see that after
all this time you're still enjoying my
content Thank You Lapidus and thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon